many people probably most people all
across the country have been unable to
get to art galleries because of the
pandemic
so one artist found a creative way to
bring the art into people's homes and
vlad's back with more on this vlad good
morning again good morning again you've
probably heard of these
little free libraries if you don't know
what they are they're little cabinets
set up in neighborhoods where people can
take and leave a book for free well now
one seattle woman
is doing that with art and while the
artwork may be tiny
it's making a world of difference
tucked away on a quiet suburban street
in seattle
sits one of the smallest art galleries
in the country
it's filled with paintings sculptures
and easels
but what you won't find is a price tag
here
at the free little art gallery you can
leave with a free piece of art
and maybe a little inspiration oh it's a
cute
keychain one of you has to take this
artist stacy mill rainey
is the mastermind behind it all all of
our museums and galleries and
other art forms have been shut down so
this is a substitute
for that right now she started making
little pieces of art back in 2019 when
she
and some of her artist friends created
tiny art to cheer her mother up during
chemotherapy treatments
when the coronavirus hit stacy took the
idea a step further
and created what she called a daily dose
of art for people stuck
in isolation i started mailing out these
little
postcard sized pieces of art so i ended
up sending about 500 of those
as you might imagine was not totally
sustainable so
inspired by the little free libraries i
thought that that might be a better way
to offer people
these little pieces of art about a day
after stacey opened the tiny space
she added some unique characters who
have taken on a life of their own
the little figures kind of added some
some
drama and a little storytelling one day
one of mill rainey's beloved characters
the chef went missing so stacy made a
missing poster
and shared it to her instagram the
original little chef didn't turn up
but to her surprise her followers from
near and
far sent her new little patrons
including a new chef
just like the old one the gallery has
attracted a community of its own
online and more than 200 pieces of art
have passed through
since its grand opening in december it
was like a shot in the arm
to the neighborhood stacy's neighbor
burton holt creates found art
and has contributed multiple times
because of the pandemic because of what
everybody's going through
and another creative outlet for people
that probably never had a creative
outlet
[Music]
it's artifacts and elements of human
expression that people can see
and when we're so separated from each
other this is a reminder that we're all
still here together we are indeed and
the artist stacey mulraney tells us that
she's received
hundreds of messages from people all
over the world who want to create their
own free little art gallery for their
neighborhoods i love this idea that
she's created this little world in the
blocks and every time you pass by
something new is in there right
soothes the soul you don't realize how
important art is in our lives until you
don't have it right
until you're isolated yes yeah that's
why when you see something like that you
go yeah
yeah you know growing up with an artist
what this means
i can't imagine life without it good
thing anthony is your house is full of
art
yes my wife would tell you a little too
much
never too much art